well hello I'm Greg and I'm John we got
sent several notifications the first one
was from Rudraksha Cahuilla first one is
sent in a request for the fate of the
Furious trailer number dos he said this
trailers batshit oh I'll tell you if
it's bad [ __ ] it sounds like a mess I
[Music]
did was enough its tools about them but
the game has changed now
[Music]
Dominic Toretto's just went rogue you
gonna turn your back on family
I know it looks that don't give up on a
filly we've only got one chance to make
this family whole again family I don't
think I can guarantee no one's ready for
that oh she's a very definition of oh
[Music]
there's no one in those cars
[Music]
Diaby keep our paths across before dawn
they need to know it all think I need to
remind you why you chose to be here if
you gotta get doc you're gonna be no
help guys you want to tell me why you
just put me in a room with this team
crumpet beam criminal mathematicians
kind of a secular school Brian you
should get the decide you guys are going
to work together left yeah I'll be
waiting back we gotta change
[Music]
don't give up dude no ma'am we thought
this was gonna be a street fight
what you doing but I know one thing you
love me
[Music]
rat out over a submarine masa is amazing
cards I could dodge torpedoes he does
not get hit by them like well I really
wanted to get behind a wall that was
pretty bad [ __ ] it was pretty bad [ __ ]
yeah it was took family three times
though I know a lot like the first time
second we decided to do a very different
thing that does limit the violent count
a little bit because whenever I saw the
trailers and they're just annihilating
all those cars in the streets like
there's a lot of innocent lives but the
trailer shows us that there's no one
even in those cars which makes it even
crazy I'm sure there are some people in
some of those cars they're not the ones
that are driving out of buildings but
I'm sure they're I jack in cars with
people inside to do they were showing oh
well most of those cars were not with
people in them don't believe us you
whatever I'm sure some was doubtful over
someone some innocent persons gonna die
of course this is like we accept that we
move on see look at all these cars are
showing what you know those cars Oh what
about all the ones that are just on the
street already those cars are not
chasing after Dominic Toretto those you
could still die no you know you're going
crushed it up like no no this family's
small this small family small family so
it looks like they're trying to link all
of them all the way back from like part
six at least they're trying to link
family just keep it growing you charlize
there was there the whole time she's a
villain he's like she's a part of this
world in the building she liked the
standouts for the space is yeah she's in
there the whole time
oh yeah it's gonna being waiting what so
hurry of Oh heaven could take the mallet
see if Jason stays that could take him
out five I'm gonna do it online
overnight
I feel like this trailer was this to do
like hey dump still good good yeah we
all doubted it we're all there going why
did Dom choose to do this I never once
thought for a second that he was being
forced in is it hahaha I just think it's
funny
so to make that clear yeah like for sure
like other [ __ ] the intrigue and now I'm
like oh good
this isn't challenging at all I like how
Dom got a little teary-eyed when he was
talking about I had no choice
yeah very odd is like look it's like
whoa is this little motion from Vin
Diesel in this movie looks like he was
hurting inside and I were he was really
hurt like the pain of a guy and this is
his family or when his lesbian
girlfriend Michelle Rodriguez was like I
know you love me any turns on this back
and she's doing uh does the Point Break
the second or better strictly Isaac just
one just one hand yeah I don't know why
he would do one hand I don't know what
that moment is don't worry we'll see it
maybe Charlie stares right above him I
just love that uh Dwayne the rock
Johnson was able to guide a torpedo
before it [ __ ] blew up or hit stuff I
could always count on the rough to do
the impossible in these movies I just I
really really really really wish I could
sit in I'm like I don't know if they
have a writers room for a movie like
this I don't know how many people work
out a script I just I wish I could be
there for the brainstorming of these
like okay okay check it out submarine
right yeah yeah but I
MMR's okay but check it out the
submarines I'm really high up so it's
like it's breaking through the edge
right we check it out this sugar torpedo
right there's like sliding online
there's a way to make cards right like
how technique opposite it is great is
good I believe they do this kind of
Cronenberg style yeah where they don't
storyboard and the actors just go for it
and do a rehearsal and then they shoot
around what the actors do totally I can
see that so why all the actors in the
stunt men are just like I don't know
spire torpedo and the rock like I got
this idea and then Disney director F you
epi Gary gray very gray and he's like
alright let's shoot that there's no
storyboarding can't predict all around
the act of Marines gonna go you know we
know that all the cast and son
and coming up with that on the fly and
then they just shot around that you know
yeah this looks like a pretty sick movie
I mean for an independent film this
looks great
yeah you know Micronesia what they're
able to go away with on a micro budget
you know it was only just a few day
masters ever since I saw the trailer for
that assassin movie where Michelle
Rodriguez is really a man you can't get
her this Damon trailer I keep thinking
of her as that character force
transaction hero which eventually maybe
for the only parts of the Fast and the
Furious movies that don't make sense now
or when you see like they dancin yeah I
like sweet racing I like the first one
through it doesn't even make sense and
he's really what why are they doing it
so we're way past the street racing yeah
the amount of like huge scale [ __ ] they
get themselves into it doesn't seem like
they would be allowed to do that this
looks like a really fun awesome time
though I just hope Kurt Russell can get
in on the action at some point yeah I
hope he gets the chance to be a be a you
know be a badass I mean this is the
second movie that Vin Diesel and corrupt
Lord doing together I know and I really
hope in both of them that he gets to you
know be a G you know be a ass at least a
little bit you know cuz laning Kurt
Russell because as you know fate of the
serious and xxx the third one yeah look
kick-ass and ever
I'm kidding Guardian guardian we all
know that Joe gardeners in Galax what I
keep saying the rules have changed I
don't know I didn't know there will be
relieved announcer versus
basically our team is possible it
doesn't seem like the rules it seems
like the teams of change yeah I'm hoping
by the end of this film that when
they're having a barbecue again you know
like a we're all still family
the rules have changes that just means
the laws of physics what's gonna happen
when they run out when they can't do
bigger anymore like what's gonna happen
when this formula runs out we mean they
could always go bigger oh I guess so
what happens when we get bored of that
like what if they need to change the
series now I'm not talking about like I
just go to space or something
I'm talking base for the Furion I'm
talking they have to fight Satan and
hell okay yeah so the rule now would be
again great pressure movie called fate
of the Furies yeah I race the definite
yeah exactly yeah how cool would that be
that's the next step yeah and bring make
it supernatural dumb break some kind of
ancient talisman a clan Julian there's a
curse you get yeah you get Hollywood
subscribe to the real rejects Jon's
reason to Jerry on Twitter and Instagram
he's a social media manager of Blum
House and the real rejects a shout out
to Brienne from hit or miss movies
Abraham she told me that when there's a
Fast and the Furious trailer out but she
wants to be a part of it the thing with
Brienne though is you gotta schedule
things in advance she was like an hour
away from me she was loose and and I
told her like a drop this morning and
then I was like trying to wait but she
wouldn't be here for hours and then by
the time I got this sub after she came
over you guys but the Cougars Ubu he was
explaining in the video you guys would
be rude to a cuckoo bird so that I just
call jawed over and now we shot it I'm
basically Brienne
yeah this would like bigger tips you
know yeah I could yeah I could play
Brandon like Hollywood Boulevard